Film Courage: Guido, you have a quote
on your Facebook. I think it was from
an interview that you did and the quote
begins with “Make sure you want it?”
Guido Segal, Screenwriter, Journalist,
Film Critic, Instructor: Yes.
Film Courage: I’m wondering can I continue?
I'll share more of what you said here,
if you want me to remind you? It's “Trust your
own talent and the singularity of your own voice.
Be careful who you listen to and if this is
what you want, don't get easily discouraged.”
What does this mean, “Make sure
you want it?” That's fascinating.
Guido: I know a lot of talented people, talented
writers, talented artists in general but talent
is only a part of the equation. I feel like in
this medium, it's so competitive and so tough
and it's so hard to get people to care. Your
talent can only get you so far. It's important
by the way you don't have to be talented I feel
like persistence and I'm not saying anything new
here but persistence is so much more important
or as important as Talent so creativity I feel
like you can develop it right you don't
have to be born creative you can nurture it
but there's a part of you that has has to hustle
so one you can't fake it if you don't want it
and this applies to actors directors writers
people can tell if you desire it and if you don't
that's totally fine and I'm not going to tell
people what line of work they should be in but
you can sense when someone really wants to tell
a story when someone wants to because writing
is not necessarily easy it's whoever tells
you writing is easy suspect that statement
I'm not saying it's the hardest thing they're
hardest jobs for sure but there's something
about writing that's exhausting because
it's it involves an emotional introspection
trying to figure out who you are what do you
want to talk about what resonates with you what
resonates with other people so it is draining
that's why I can only write a certain amount
of pages a day because I want to write something
that's truthful and writing truthful Pages takes a
lot of energy a lot of thought a lot of asking
questions a lot of doubt that's why I didn't
mean that quote to be daunting what is if you
really want to do this then no one can stop you
just there can be failure along the way that there
can be many frustrations daily every writer will
know this some days you just write great Pages
some days it doesn't work some days you write
bad or bad Pages or you get rejections or you
get awful notes notes that you don't know what
to do with like how am I going to apply this note
and it's a job you can't say no right so what I
meant is if the desire is there if the flame is
within you then you got the most important thing
how should someone quote unquote check themselves
to know if they really want it because I think we
all think we want certain things and then once we
go through the process day in and day out then it
becomes clear to us what it actually is yeah I
it's a good question so I don't I don't intend
to be a guru of any sorts and sometimes the line
is a bit blurry between like self-help and but
it is a very intimate thing to me at least writing
is a very intimate thing very personal thing
even if I'm not writing about my own life
which I rarely do it is incredibly person
I care about it and there are moments of Doubt
of course there were moments and there are still
moments when I wonder is this the best way
to channel my abilities my skills my talent
the truth is over the years I keep doing it and
the fact that I keep going back to it means that
I actually care that to me is the the best
evidence that am a writer this is not a hobby
this is not something that I'm good at I'm good at
certain things that I don't necessarily spend time
on I don't know I guess I could have been a good
lawyer I've thought about this many times I would
have certainly made more money I would have been
more stable my dad would have been delighted but
that's not how it went there's a Creative Energy
there's a need to express yourself through stories
because I've I've been a film critic for 10
years before actually become a screenwriter
and that's that's a long story how
I became a film critic I don't think
any child any eight ten-year-old child
says I want to become a film critic right
but it happened and I'm I'm glad it did
but being a journalist or writing in that
film analysis which I did that's not that's
a whole different approach it's still writing
but it's not a it is creative but it's it's it's
not the same way to apply your your emotion your
brain it's very different so at some point I
had to question myself do I want to analyze
a film that's already made and out there someone
else's work or do I want to produce my own work
and that takes courage and that takes facing your
fears and limitations and it's it's it's really
hard to write a script if you were an attorney
presenting your own case so you were you were
employed by Guido Segal and you were speaking
to the jury about why Guido should continue
on this path so ladies and gentlemen of the jury
I present to you my client and and he really wants
this he's not sure if it'll ever pan out or I
don't know what would what would the argument
be how would you convince 12 jurors with their
arms crossed that I guess what I would say is
I like a good challenge and this is the most
challenging and exciting thing that I've found
I don't I don't know if I could have been a doctor
in the sense that I couldn't do the same thing
over and over and over again and with writing
it's always new no script is or play I guess
or novel they're never the same so with practice
you get better at it but every new story you face
or you have to break down post this new a new set
of new challenges and that to me is very exciting
so persistence we're going back to what you
said originally that Talent necessarily it's
not always in the equation it's persistence yeah
and especially in in a city like La there's so
many talented people and I don't say this lightly
I've met so many talented writers that come from
all over the country all over the world and
they're here for a reason but to make it here
I'm again I don't want to be the one saying what
it means to make it I would say to get a job or
to have several jobs that just just to be paid to
write means a lot I want to be very realistic of
course you need a dream we all have one or many
dreams but I think my goal is to keep to be paid
to write and that to me is the dream it's so maybe
I've become older and jaded and more realistic
but it's so hard to get paid to the right to
write to get paid to be an artist a creative
so you have to constantly negotiate with what
the industry wants and the standards and what
you want and it's not necessarily the same of
course when you get to I guess to a certain
point in your career that you're in control you
can decide but still remember met Paul feig right
who did I wrote and directed bridesmaids among
Ghostbusters among many other things and I asked
him Paul when is the right time to do your passion
project and he said never never is the right time
and you just do it if you
want but know that it's risky
when you were in grade school or as
a teenager were you bored in school
no I actually I gotta I was I was a nerd I was
very I wasn't a troublemaker I actually loved
loved school I know that's not a common thing
to say but I loved learning I loved history
I did okay with math and physics and chemistry
all those subjects but literature history
later on philosophy like I connected to all
that and I love I've always loved reading
I guess when I decided to be a filmmaker and I
still dream about directing I don't know I don't
think I'm a director by Nature because I love
words I work with words and that's why since I
love films and I love literature I'm a writer and
it makes so much sense for me to be a screenwriter
but no I actually love school
and grad school and and college
was the passion project ever the right
time did you find time to make yours
or it's still in the works well it's had a TV
I have a TV show that I've developed that I've
written the pilot and it's been in development
for three years and it's period and again I don't
make it easy on myself it's it's an expensive
show it's period it's about the 60s in Chicago
sorry to interrupt I well by the way this is the
thing didn't set out to be a period writer but
I guess it's it resonates with me so wrote one
show that takes place in the late 60s in Chicago
that I don't think that's gonna happen by the way
because they the way I make the movie think it's
about the young Lords and of course I'm me not
being Puerto Rican doesn't help I got very I met
some of those historical figures
I interviewed them it was really
interesting but Sometimes some things don't
pan out and you just let them go and that's
this show no the show is is takes place mostly
in Boston in the 60s it's about psychedelics
and you just gotta be patient I've written
that script so many times and Rewritten it and
it takes time and money and getting people
attached this is about Timothy Leary yes it is
okay I as growing up in San Francisco knew his
name a lot and around interest yeah so that's
adapted this author who now became my
friend Robert Greenfield and Bob wrote
about all these figures in the 60s like the
Grateful Dead Jerry Garcia and the Grateful
Dead Timothy Leary so I adapted Bob and we
became friends and he's like a mentor to me now
so that opened up that script opened up other
doors to writing about the 60s and rock and roll
and psychedelics and and I clearly connect even
though I wasn't born around that time I connect
to that I felt the same way even though I'm a gen
xer so yeah but there was something about being
there and just seeing just The Counter Culture
movement that was very attractive and and yeah
what I suspect or what I feel at least is that
we have an idea of those of those times and a
feeling that there was a dream of how Society
could have been and then it didn't work out
but for for a few years it felt like America at
least could become place where there was a certain
amount of freedom and and people were against the
Vietnam War and expansion of consciousness and
and I feel like a lot of what's happening
today is still is is the the the effect of
those of those days like we're still we're
going back to some of the ideas and theories
back in the day I'm seduced by the idea of of a
different Society where everyone's welcome and you
have a certain amount of freedom to do what
you do as long as you don't hurt other people
I guess that's why I go back to the 60s or my idea
of the 60s and is that one of the reasons you say
you don't make it easy on yourself and that
doing doing the time diff in terms of costumes
and cars and and getting the rights to music
and things like that would be a lot certainly
period by itself you can see producers get scared
because we're talking if it's a TV show we're
talking about at least a two million dollar
episode in a 10 episode season at least I'm saying
right so it's costumes it's cars if it's based on
real people it's having the IP which which I do
but it's more challenging so get this note or this
comment constantly which is why don't you write
something contemporary based on your own story
and I usually reply to this there is a lot
of me in what you read the fact that it's not
autobiographical doesn't mean it's not incredibly
personal I have I have been trying this is the
thing this it's everyone has their own approach
I don't like to write about myself explicitly
I don't feel like it's necessary but
everyone's free to do whatever they feel
sure incorporate parts of my life and anecdotes
into my writing but I give it to someone else
that's my Approach without asking anyone
for feedback how do you have a good story
wow that's an interesting question I think
every every writer or every creative we have
an intuition and over time you you learn how to
listen to that intuition and and you know the
scene is working or not if the script is working
or not usually when you when you finish a draft
my immediate reaction usually is I'm very proud
of myself even though I won't say it out loud
but I I'm satisfied and after a couple of days
I start seeing the gaps or I start seeing the
flaws it's like my first reaction is okay
at least I managed to put this on paper
then you go back to it and always I'm
always a bit scared to go back to it because
when you're when you're actually on a roll it's
like a trance and sometimes you don't you're not
necessarily conscious of what's going in there
you're following your own the the scribble of the
scene and then you try to make it work and come
to life a life so when you go back to you have
a feeling which scenes are working which scenes
are not which scenes need to be totally Rewritten
of course then you can ask for feedback and and
what I'd say about feedback is I always try to
be extremely careful about who I ask feedback
for so it has to be a limited number of people
as sweet people I really that people who know
what I'm trying to achieve and who are not trying
to change what I'm what my my goal is but who
or trying to help me make it work because it's
extremely sensitive even you're not entirely sure
at least I don't know any writer who's 100 sure
unless if you're working for a TV show and and
you have this very detailed outline well then
you're just following instructions right but if
it's your own script something you didn't expect
you're never entirely sure so pick three or four
people you really trust who who love your your
baby because that's what it is as you as you do
who will read carefully and who are considerate
and who'll give you honest feedback that's not
bringing you down I've made that mistake in the
past where I was trying to impress someone and
I gave them my first or second or third draft
and the notes that God destroyed me and it's
really hard to recover from that because you're
still not sure what you're people might say like
I wrote a great script again I'm suspicious it's
it's it's a script is something very flexible you
you might have a very clear plan but things change
along the way you have to let them change
it has to evolve you want it to be organic
so I always I have my people and they're
always the same people and and those who
haven't given me good notes or careful notes in
the past I don't send them any scripts anymore
unless of course it's producers you're working for
a director you're working for or even your reps
let's let's be honest you're I'd love to
have reps who totally understand what I'm
doing it's not always the case maybe you're a
manager or your agent don't they they believe
in your potential maybe they don't connect to
your writing and then well it's a matter of
when do you choose to to present your material
or if you have the the correct representation
new screenwriter sitting across from you and
they said I gave my script to several people
and one person I really respect their opinion
but they destroyed me with their notes and you
wouldn't think that because we have a
great relationship what would be your
advice to them why do you think
somebody would purposely try to do that
I think everyone has good and bad days and we we
never know what the other person's going through
and I say this after years of dealing with
terrible notes that make me feel awful okay
so it's not like I've become enlightened
but I had to deal with this so with when
you send out things to contests or people read
your submission or even people and respect
maybe they're having the worst day of their lives
and they will hate they will hate your script no
matter how good it is also people don't people
don't like reading scripts that's I've that's my
conclusion you really gotta insist and people will
love your script reluctantly that means for some
reason no one has ever has time to read scripts
they'll do it two weeks later a month later
but when you've actually written a
really good script that you worked on
people have no choice but to admit how good
it is and actually I've I remember doing
internship internships back in the day and
reading scripts and you don't want to like
those scripts because you're a writer
and they're writers and you don't want
other writers to succeed by the way you should
learn to be okay with other people's success
it takes time but no one's success impacts yours
there's no connection okay you're not a failure
because they're succeeding and the sooner you
acknowledge this the better life you'll have
which is everyone's doing their own thing no one's
taking anything away from you so I remember the
feeling of being an intern or working for doing
coverage and and you read scripts and whenever
you find one that actually clicks it's an amazing
thing like oh my God this script is actually great
there's so many bad scripts out there and that's
fine it's really hard to write a good script but
I would say whenever you get terrible notes
just try to be understanding probably the other
person's having a personal issue maybe they're
frustrated with their career maybe things didn't
work out because there's really no need to destroy
anyone's script that's my my opinion if we were
going to take the same new screenwriter and
they asked well how do I know I have a yes
person who might be reading my script so it's
a person who doesn't want to hurt my feelings
or maybe there's an agenda they want to keep the
friendship for whatever reason how do how do you
decipher someone who's just giving you fluff
you mean professionally it's something that's
leading nowhere feedback on a script so it could
be a friend it could be a manager somebody that
just they just want to tell you yes they want to
keep you happy but it's actually not constructive
well what I would say is what do you want from
feedback you don't want of course our egos need a
little attention so when someone says I loved your
script it's so good there's a second where you
appreciate it because you need validation but then
there's nothing you can do with that and if you're
honest with yourself you don't really believe that
your script is perfect and I'm not saying that you
should work on it endlessly because there comes a
time when you have to stop and you have to move on
and there's a fine line between
rewrites and then just over rewriting it
of course unless you're getting paid and then
you have no choice what I would say is you
you try people out first of all this intuition I
mentioned right so your intuition says this person
is mindful this this person might understand what
I'm trying to do they're generous with their time
because a lot of people are they can be
great individuals they're not really generous
because in order to read someone's script you
need to take time to read it and take notes and
actually give them something back if you're
just going to read it in a hurry and and say
like oh my God you're such a good writer great
job you haven't really done the work you haven't
really considered I know my script is not perfect
that's why I gave it to you so if you feel people
out you try it usually you know when they give you
notes that if it's going to work out or not it's
like next time I think I'll go with someone else
because you actually want honest feedback like
what did you like what did you connect with what's
working what's not working did you find anything
outlandish or outrageous some people might even
hopefully not but they might even get offended
like why are you offended are you offended
in a good way like is this is this causing
contradictions that make you think or is this
actually offensive and I should reconsider it
in terms of topics writer content so I think it's
trial and error and with time you find your people
with with reps well that's that's a whole
different chapter because reps I've had
several over the years and it's it's hard it's
almost like a like a like a love relationship
you gotta find your person and agent agents
you don't expect much in terms of creative
conversation with with an agent but with a manager
you can not always though sometimes your manager's
notes might be this is not new enough I need
something new because they're trying to sell
and it's like well I don't really know what to
do with that what does that mean why do I know
what new is so that's it's different because
they're not your friend they can be but there's
mutual interest in that you produce something that
sells and they want to sell it but with colleagues
and friends I feel like you gotta sense it like
okay this person cares this person is generous
and a lot of people are not unfortunately it's a
tricky thing and I don't mean to contradict what
you're saying but with generosity I think that
especially maybe here in La there are a lot of
takers and I know that's not a popular thing to
say but I'm just going to say it and so I think
when people they have to be guarded with their
time yeah that's the only thing I can throw out
about that well I feel like La is a double-edged
sword in the sense that you gotta be here because
this is where the opportunity happens and that is
still true even though last year when the pandemic
was at its worst I feel like you didn't have to
be here but usually you do with meetings in person
at least or events events where you can actually
meet certain people and that's tricky too because
the thing with networking I'm I'm transitioning
to a whole different chapter well the thing with
networking is that you don't just go to parties
and meet someone and get a job you got to build
a relationship and the hardest part about La
is actually building meaningful relationships
and it's about the work you produce but it's
also about a personal connection that's real
people when you actually like someone and
they like you back and you can have dinner
and you don't have to talk about work
at dinner you're just hanging out
but if you if you have something to offer
and they actually like you and you like them
the odds are they're going to call you so it's
that it's not what you do it's who well it is
about what you do but having a personal connection
that's real doesn't hurt sure I think that's where
it's a challenge yeah and it is true look it is
it is true that a lot of people in this town are
really desperate so they are selfish but also
it's really they're trying to make a living
sorry I'm really trying to be understanding
with everyone like I you can get you can get
upset and judge people and think they're
superficial or or that their Ambitions are
over the top but it is a
very competitive environment
and people are just trying to get jobs so try
to find your people and and if someone is not
your crowd then that's fine sure and it's a very
expensive place to live and it's competitive
not just jobs but survival jobs apartments
everything so you're constantly in this Loop
of competition waiting for something and
so it's hard to maybe the generosity it's
not that they don't want to help someone
it's just maybe they're all tapped out
everyone's here to quote unquote make it right and
again whatever that means and I say that because
everyone's careers have ups and downs right and
when you're at your lowest then maybe the next
day things just pick up incredibly so even for
Highly Successful People nothing's guaranteed
right you might you might be incredibly successful
making a lot of money and have a deal with Amazon
or Netflix or Apple and then your show is
a flop and then you're vanished right so
it's it's ups and downs it's really hard to build
meaningful relationship in a town where everyone's
trying to find their Niche and trying to find
stability I'd say that the worst thing about being
a writer or a Creator is the lack of stability we
all I think we all crave it at some point that's
why I like teaching because it gives me a certain
stability and a certain steady income right
there's nothing wrong with having a plan B for
the times when things don't work out even even
if you have writing jobs contract negotiations
can take forever and I'll never understand why
because I'm not involved in that part but they
might take months so you're waiting on a on a
sure thing and you're going to get paid and you're
going to have just have to sit down and write but
reps and lawyers and and there's something going
on behind the curtain that you don't get to see
and you just have to be patient so either find
a hobby or get on a side gig love teaching
I love the interaction with students I've I've
done educational content I every once in a while
I started out by making film related content and
then I ended up this year I wrote units on ethics
and Community for example and I didn't
expect that to happen that was exciting
yeah but it's an income it's stimulating I
learn so you gotta open up like half different
Avenues open going back to what you said about
writing and it being hard think you've posted
that you like Gore Vidal the author and I know
he he's not worried about offending anyone or
it's just saying what he feels and one quote
I have here from him is some writers take to
drink others take to audiences [Laughter]
I don't know if many people nowadays are
I've read first of all he's incredibly prolific
I can't believe that man and by the way he's
he's overlooked in general he's his whole take on
American history he's written about many relevant
figures and periods of American history and he's
incredibly talented and insightful especially love
his rivalry with William Buckley Jr there's a
documentary called best of enemies and I think
Aaron Sorkin at some point was going to make
that movie and I would have loved to see that
I just enjoyed it all and envy or I'd say no I
admire more than Envy I admire how disciplined
and prolific he was in terms of writing or any
kind of stimuli involved I I'm a get I drink
coffee and right and in terms of audiences try
not to think too much about that because you you
might you might get lost thinking about like who
am I writing for you just try to be very personal
and very honest and hope for the best that just
hope that someone cares and one last follow-up
quote from Gord vadal the four most beautiful
words in our common language I told you so
[Laughter] look he was he was a pro guitar so I'm
I don't know what he actually means but I told
you so which is probably one of the worst things
you can tell anyone no one's no one ever reacted
well to that sentence right but he did like to
provoke a lot he liked confrontation [Music]
actually I think Vidal and and Buckley invented
the the figure of the pundit I don't think before
1968 when they had those presidential debates
journalists broadcasting news was just it tried
to be objective the idea of having someone
Express opinions and debate it wasn't a thing
so I think I admire of it all as as a novelist
as a screenwriter as a playwright as a pundit
just one of those figures that find in
stimulating and I also admire his intellect
what are three things every great story has
well I think I want to be a little bit obvious
here but I think a great opening you need a
hook especially nowadays that people are so
distracted and there's so much to read and watch
and so a great hook a great opening that offers a
question Intrigue so I'll say that of course if I
say a great opening I have to say a great ending
and usually I'd say when I write that's those
are the two things I think of first I need to
know where I'm starting off from and I need to
know where I need to get to and the beauty or
the challenge is okay how do I get from point A to
point B but I'm going to say the third element is
a a great character or characters I think one of
the most difficult things things to do is to find
characters that feel real or possible and not just
ideas but that feel like people and that's why
the Temptation is always to steal from someone
and what is think of people in your life and
and you you never I personally I don't ever
do just one person I don't I'm not trying to
portray a single individual I'm taking different
elements it's a composite of different people
well the character I would say though
there has to be an emotional connection and
with this it's very easy to have ideas and
then apply them and the risk with ideas is
that you're not connected to them they just
sound great they sound original but if there's
no emotional connection to you you can sense it
you feel it's cold right it's it's too rational
so with character you I try to find that emotional
connection why do I relate to this trait why are
the certain quality right why do I want to keep
seeing this why do I want to write about this
so I'd say a great beginning a great ending
and at least one singular memorable character
can you give me an example of a character
of film or television that definitely seems
real you could see them once the movie ends
they're still living their life somewhere and
then the opposite one that maybe was all
hype but really it felt one-dimensional
um well this is the the first the first character
I used this in class because the way it's written
it's it's just I'd say memorable is the word so
With The Big Lebowski the way it the way he's
into the character is introduced in the script
the way it's written and the way we see it on
screen is just that we know that guy right I
don't know him I don't know him exactly like
that but that that guy exists and he's so la he's
so Venice to be specific and I don't we don't know
how he makes a living and he's funny and he's
high all the time and he's by the way so he's
at Ralph's at 3am in a bathrobe with sunglasses
and he pays for a carton of milk with a check
right so it's like who is this guy I know
him he's just by looking at him I'm laughing
and that's because I recognize that character and
he's memorable so coin brothers are so good at
that but if we take the graduate Benjamin in The
Graduate for example a totally different character
more grounded recognize that guy as well I'm sorry
I'm just mentioning male characters I'm sure I can
find female ones too but what I'm saying is those
are people I can relate to and if I can relate to
them it's because they're specific enough and
you can come from a totally different that's
the beauty of of art you come from a different
culture a different background and even different
gender and you connect because there's something
about the human experience that you see there
I don't know if I can I remember the quote but I
David Lynch who I was listening to on a podcast
yesterday said find the thing that by knowing it
all there is to be known and what that basically
means is if you capture a little thing that's
real you're capturing truth in general and
people connect to that that sounds very abstract
but what it means is the more specific you are
with your characters the more with what they
like what they don't like what they do how
they like their coffee and I tell students this
all the time ask as many questions as possible
try to try to enjoy the process of getting
to know your characters as if you were
knowing someone you just met and then the
opposite a character or characters that
there was a lot of hype around the film or
the television show but they fell flat to you
that's a tricky one because have to criticize
someone's work I off the top of my head don't
know I can usually this is the thing big
franchises don't have great characters
because it doesn't matter and I don't want to
be cheap and and so I enjoy the Fast and the
Furious movies because I do watch them they get
more bloated and more insane by by the movie so
those are not really characters they're tropes and
it it's okay because maybe those movies don't need
characters I think that's that's a choice I don't
think that's an accident action movies in general
you don't need characters to be too deep right
they just need to be resilient and bleed and fight
we go back to the graduate Mrs Robinson
yeah was she was she three-dimensional oh
definitely well there is no movie without
her right it's Benjamin and Mrs Robinson
and and this is what's interesting when I first
watched it I think in my probably as a teenager
I don't think I understood her that well
as you get as you get older you you get
her predicament more clearly it's like
oh see where she is in life I see why she
feels unfulfilled I see why she would flirt with
this youngster it's such a complex character and
I feel like if you can get characters to
do anything and you can still understand
their motivation and their contradictions and
relate to them then that's that to me is success
you talked about great openings have there been
excellent films that had kind of weak openings or
is that always a through line great films great
openings you can't have one without the other
I'm think I'm thinking I'm thinking I know there
are films that take their time to get there um
see the thing is I those are the ones
I forget great openings are memorable
I always say that things you forget are because
not because you have a problem maybe you have a
neurological problem but mostly the things
I forget is because they were not memorable
and what's memorable memorable and what's
not that's another question but I do know
the do know which openings I remember every
single time and that's because they're great
and I could say for example the opening of Back
to the Future right I remember that exactly
why is it that that because that's a perfect
script in its own genre right the same with
Indiana Jones I don't know even The Exorcist
the great openings are I'm talking movies I
could talk TV as well Breaking Bad all sorts of
examples but great openings are always memorable
the reason I can't think of any negative examples
is because I've forgotten bad there's really I
have no need to Archive that to save that in my
in my brain archive because the ones I've been
over and over again are the ones that I take
as examples where does the creation of a great
story begin I feel like every every creative has
a different source of inspiration or motivation
maybe it's a feeling maybe it's an image
maybe it's a Memory maybe all of them combined
um I usually to me there's usually an image and
that image is going to guide me along the way
when I feel lost in the story I go back
to that and that image usually contains
at least one emotion that I don't maybe I
don't fully understand it but I will explore
that through the story so to me it's yeah
I would say an image or a series of images
that contain in them the whole story
um and it's it's the most mysterious
thing because can't fully explain it
suddenly I'll be talking to someone or I'll be
reading right something or listening to music
to a song or and some or or someone will tell me
a story like the other day I bought this doll and
I gave it to my daughter and and suddenly I hear
this and there's there are coordinates there that
make me resonate and I know that because I keep
thinking about it so if if after a couple of days
I keep thinking about it and I'm talking about
Original Stories no it's very different if you get
a commission like please write this story right if
it's an original thing if I keep thinking about it
and especially if I can tie to that other elements
that I'm interested in you start building a world
right and I know for example when Hitchcock
did South North by Northwest there was no story
originally he had a series of scenes he wanted to
shoot and then he brought brought in Ernest Layman
who's one of the best writers ever and then
they came up with a story to tie those scenes
together but what he knew at first is he had these
images a guy hanging from Mount Rushmore right so
a guy shoots someone at the U.N building and
that's perfectly okay of course he's Hitchcock
he knew everything but and then you you tie
those scenes together and you have a story
I like what Howard Howard Suber who taught at
UCLA for 50 years but he calls by association
which is when you bring together two elements
that wouldn't necessarily coexist but when you do
something new comes out right so and this happens
in life all the time so for example if you're
shooting underwater and you introduce I don't
know there's a fireplace down there I'm being
extreme it doesn't belong there but with that
trigger this is a series of Connections mental
connections right where suddenly you have to make
that work checkup did this in in theater all the
time right introducing an element that doesn't
belong and that that can set the story in motion
so going back to your original question I think
it's images that have an emotional backbone and I
have to figure out what that means to me and then
the story will very slowly with patience come out
and one thing I'd like to say about that is
you got to be very careful because you got
to be patient with it and also don't let
it drag you got to find a certain balance
because sometimes you just want to rush it
you're like I want to know what the story is
and you'll have a lot of good ideas but they're
not necessarily clicking so sometimes I'll do
a very quick outline and then I go back to it
and realize this stays this has to go this is
not really honest this is me trying to get out
of of this situation quick enough to move on
it's a very organic process of discovery you
don't always have the luxury of time I'm saying
ideally if you do you want to find a balance
between taking your time and not wasting time
is that normal what's your
story if you feel enough
of a pull toward it whether it's about you
personally or a character that you really
have fondness for new writers if would you tell
them that you will feel lost writing your story
oh absolutely I wish someone had told me that
you get lost you get lost I get lost very often
and you get lost mostly not not because
you don't know what you want mostly because
of expectations so sometimes you have an intuition
and that intuition says something but you want to
make it so much better and so original and that
you keep pushing and suddenly you have doubts
and you have to try to go back
to that original impulse right
and again the more time you spend with it the the
more chances you'll get of figuring it out but
this is the tricky to me see to me that
the most difficult thing is not the writing
itself it's figuring out what you want to
write the heavy lifting to me is coming up
with a story on the characters and the beats
once I have all that writing is just a joy
so the writing itself is not that that
complicated it's knowing what I have to write
once I have that the story all mapped
out and the characters and I'm confident
because that gives me confidence and once I
once I'm confident I can actually play with it
it's a joy but it's not easy no it's not easy but
it's like playing a sport only every time you you
go out there you have to learn the rules
again once the rules okay what the options
you have right and and you come out certain
place you come up in the spur of the moment
certain places you have practiced before what
I'm saying is that it's not that it's easy it's
just what I'm confident it's because I've done
my homework and when I've when I've got that
in my head then I can improvise a little bit
so I know the scene starts here and ends here
I'm gonna add a little flare here that without
extending myself too much yes I can actually that
little flare might have a narrative purpose right
I'll give you a small example for example I would
I was writing this scene and then where this
character is trying to impress this woman is
trying to impress an older woman who she sees as
a mentor right and they're at these older woman's
house and the older woman says let's go upstairs
I want to show you something but please would you
mind taking your shoes off and I thought what
if she is a broken saw her sock is torn right
and it's so embarrassing and at first I thought
that's amazing and then I thought well what is
does it fit into the story or am I but I realize
it's such a character trait and it's such it's
there's a narrative purpose if you're trying
to impress someone you'll be very embarrassed
so not only did it stay it made the scene or you
didn't get a pedicure that week and you're you're
yeah your feet look horrible anything that makes
you look other than what you want to be perceived
as right for you maybe her husband will say like
it's not a big deal honey and she'll be like yes
it is a big deal it might be right some people
it would be yeah well if you think of me I'm like
she thought you were amazing until she saw your
foot so that's you gotta right but that only comes
out once your world and your characters sure
sure and the relationships right I could see
that being a real thing because you go to people's
homes all the time oh do you mind taking off your
shoes oh no no problem and then you go oh that's
right and then you're thinking oh no yeah what
are you gonna think how didn't I think of this
in advance and that makes the character real
what's your writing process my writing process
it starts off with a procrastination and I gotta
say this because every writer does it and it's
terrible I don't recommend it but no let's be
honest writing starts off with an idea right and
you get excited about this idea and you have to
write it down again I'm talking about writing on
spec it's very different if you're coming in to
write something or if there's a pre-existing let's
start off with writing on spec and I'll answer
the question separately if about writing based on
someone else's material so if it's my own script
there's an idea and I'm very excited
about it and I need to write it down and
I need to capture it as best as I can right so I
usually might be on my computer or might be just
I hadn't written right and I'll take
a notebook and I'll start writing
and of course I'm very satisfied with that but
then you realize okay this idea is not the story
right everyone has a great idea but then you have
to break down break it down into characters and
beats and it's so much more complex and of course
it will change because D great ideas don't make
great movies they can help but great movies need
events right and conflict and characters and so on
so you start breaking at some point you
start breaking down the story you get
very frustrated because now it's real right
ideas are up there flying in the air but
then you're breaking it down and now it's got
it's gotten real so you start breaking it down
and you explore characters separately and if
some people do backstory I discover backstory
as I go along some people start off from theme
I Love Theme by the way it's something I think
about I tend to think of theme as a question some
people some people will use words right like um
Love full potential right I don't know what to do
with with those words and in terms of practical
writing like it's a story about love sure but what
do I do with that so to me themes are more more of
a question more of a specific question it might
be a movie about sports but then the theme is
how does it feel like to not be recognized by
your father right for example so it's something
I can relate to and then I can explore and the
story is an answer to that question in a way
so once I have the idea I start breaking down
separately character and backstory the world right
if it's period I have to do research and I
love research I actually love it so much that
I would spend my entire life just doing research
love going reading books watching movies going
to library sometimes great the New York Public
Library has an amazing archive and you go there in
the back with your little gloves and then you just
spend hours going through original letters and
had a blast doing that so research not too
much because at some point it can drive you
mad so at some point you got to stop with
research and start I'm making things up
and once you have like the world the characters
the beats and now you're ready to start writing
if it's if it's based on someone else's material
then [Music] well I guess instead of coming up
with the Beats you're trying to find those
beats in the book or the source material and
the characters the beauty of adaptations is that
characters are given still it doesn't mean that
you're going to take everything in there you gotta
learn what to take and what to discard of course
a friend who's a producer the
other day was telling me that
movies are not novels movies are short stories
and and short films are like poems so there's
not a lot of beats in a movie even if you're doing
a three hour long movie there's not an infinite
amount of Beats novels have so much material
that you gotta weed out what stays and what goes
so it might seem like you have a lot of real
estate to to develop your story but you don't
an average 100 minute movie is I'd say about
36 to 40 Beats maybe maybe more if it's really
fast-paced but you only have a certain amount of
seams in a 90-minute script you have 33 minute
scenes again it's not math but what I'm saying is
you really gotta pick what you're gonna focus on
it doesn't matter if it's an adaptation on your
own work for your script regarding Timothy Leary
since he had such a vast long life sure when he
passed away he took his life correct he died in
the eye in the late 90s he was already in his
80s okay how did what you what time period or
did what did you cover most of it well actually
it took me several drafts to figure that out
I knew it had to start in the 60s the first
draft I wrote of the script started in 1963
which is when he gets kicked out of Harvard
because he gave students psilocybin and LSD
but then I realized I had to go back I had to
start it off in 1960 which is when he gets hired
at Harvard Harvard because it's he's 40 years
old he's going through a middle-aged age crisis
his wife first wife has just committed suicide
recently no one knows about this so I figured
I gotta start at the beginning and sometimes
it's not easy to know where the beginning is
it's really up to you so I actually wrote I
think like two drafts that took place in 63
and then I went back to 1960 which is the
current version and then the beauty of it
is you can have at least five or six seasons
if you wanted because every stage of his life
is a different whole different thing Harvard
California New York Afghanistan Switzerland
[Music] but only I wrote the first draft based on
the book and then I went to the public library in
New York where there are approximately 463 I think
boxes of his belongings wow his personal archive
and rifled through that and I didn't get to All
the Boxes by the way because that's Insanity
I did go through a lot of them over several
trips and it was there's nothing I like better
than spending time with studying original sources
right and then he had a subsequent relationship
with someone that he cared very deeply for
didn't he but it's debatable whether she was
hired to spy on him oh there was a
documentary that came out recently
by Errol Morris I think it's his fourth wife
Joanna Harcourt Smith Leary had several wives
well there was a whole debate I had with the
producer who was who's a friend of mine and who
was convinced that Lee was a saint and I had to
tell him no he was this man was incredibly flawed
very responsible we I think he's our way
into the Counter Culture and telling that
whole story I don't think we should
use this man as an example of anything
because he for for decades he talked about
the death of ego and he had nothing but ego
actually he was married to I think five
amazing women and he disrespected all of
them and he could never he could never love them
the way they loved him and it's actually tragic I
know I hope none of the fans hilarious fans are
listening because they're going to kill me but
I think he's a very contradictory man very he
had the he had the charm he could lure people in
he's very smart but I think the the the one
in that relationship the one who actually
transcended all that was Richard Alpert who
became ramdas so in the show we have Leary who's
who's a voice of this whole movement but in
a way I feel like he's disingenuous and you
have ramdas who actually did go to India and
transcend ego and became this beautiful being
can you explain how you outline
a screenplay yeah so outlines
I'd say so first you have the idea right
or you have the the concept so to speak
and some people have high Concepts like
which are easier to explain in in a few words
I usually have low Concepts in the sense that
they're character driven and that's in a way
it's more challenging because you gotta find out
what makes them distinctive from other ideas the
maybe the juice the beauty of it is not in the
concept but in in the world in the character
so do a beat sheet first and I use an exercise
that Hal Ackerman talks about who I had class
with a UCLA called snow plowing and snow plowing
is basically you set out a certain amount of
time could be 20 minutes could be 40 or an hour
usually you don't do more than an hour at a time
and you write down possible scenes without judging
them and not not stopping right so it doesn't
matter if they contradict one another you just
keep going so because they're just possibilities
they're not the whole final thing and ideally
you you write I don't use a computer then I
just write it down manually and let's say you do
20 minutes and you just go non-stop don't because
if you stop you're gonna judge it and the point
is not to judge yourself the point is to discover
so you do this exercise a few times over and over
again and then you go back to it and then you pick
and discard like okay this is good this one not
doesn't work or I'm gonna just pick this option
and I'd say after a few times of doing that you
start having a sense of what the structure is
of course you can also guide yourself with
with books right now save the cat has as
an option of what a structure is I feel
like intuitively that your structure needs
ups and downs and and beats of all kinds and
you kind of have a midpoint so by doing by snow
plowing and then by going back to the idea of
structure you come up with a beats and once you
have the Beats which are the bones the outline
is like giving that connective tissue right so
once I'm confident about my beachy then I just
start filling out those bones with yeah with
flesh which is not too much detail but enough
detail to connect the scenes and make sure that
there's a cause and effect relationship between
them and you just expand so I would say there's
I don't skip any of the steps from idea I go to
beat sheet from beachy I go to outline I don't
need my outlines to be too detailed I just need
them to have the necessary information especially
if I want to have like setups and payoffs I
want to make sure those are in the outline
um and then you just start writing
when you're writing these scenes that you don't
want to judge and they might be random scenes
are they ones you've already had in your mind or
are you almost manufacturing them so that the most
ridiculous idea like this would never really
happen and then once you go back and look at it
you think well actually we could lead to that no
the point is to to surprise yourself actually um
so I it's a very different the creative mind that
you apply is very different you have like your
right side of the brain and your left side of the
brain right and I feel like most of the time in
the real world we're we're being very rational so
if you start writing from that perspective you're
going to come up with probably conventional ideas
and there's nothing wrong with cliches by the way
I think they're a great starting point when you
don't know what to do just write down the cliche
so you can get it out of the way that's better
than nothing and sometimes I feel we get blocked
because you try to write the most original thing
ever and you don't do that right away it's really
hard so maybe it's easier to write a cliche and
then maybe change a few things and and maybe let
it evolve and turn or for example always want to
set a scene in the most original location right
so instead of setting it at the character's
house which would be the obvious thing because
they're going to discuss something intimate
what if they're in church right and that of
course makes the conversation more awkward and
maybe funny and they can't really talk great but
is that does it serve the story you don't want to
be eccentric just for the sake of being eccentric
but maybe maybe you plan the scene in the
character's house and then once you have it okay
what if I change the location and maybe and maybe
it works but you don't you don't go all the way at
once you want to take it gradually and once you
have it okay if I change location would she say
this in public if she said this in public maybe
it's funny maybe it's ridiculous I don't know
sorry I got lost in my my own logic there oh
yeah so originality I feel like it's desirable
to be original and you don't want to be lazy
but sometimes some scenes can only take place
in one location right if the character is in
prison they're not infinite options right if
someone's visiting they can only meet in the
visiting space right there's no other option
but if you have time and and and and and
you want to make it better maybe explore
with certain scenes unexpected locations
can you give me examples of these cliches
what's a cliche well with characters it's
easy because stereotypes and archetypes right
and we see this all all the time so the cop the
preacher the prostitute right the bossy wife
um you don't want to play those characters
exactly the way it as they sound because
we've seen that and it's boring and if if
the audience is smart let's not underestimate
the audience the audience has seen a lot of
movies read a lot of books whatever they know
so if you're gonna play with stereotypes or
archetypes you better find a way to make them
slightly different or maybe start Tony Soprano
right Tony Soprano is a gangster that goes to
therapy if he was just a gangster they'll be like
okay I've seen Good Fellas what's why am I even
watching this but Tony Soprano has an issue
again I'm going to very classic example but
he has an emotional issue he's a gangster and
now it doesn't surprise us but back in the day
with The Sopranos what 95 96 I don't know when
it came out it was it was an amazing concept
um and sometimes I'm it happened to me I have to
write gangsters so what do I do with gangsters
what haven't I seen with gangsters I don't
know gangster singing gangsters
crying what can I do with them
gangster that doesn't want to be a gangster
but has to swearsed by his family yeah or her
family yeah that could lead somewhere as long
as you can find to me the most difficult thing
is finding the yeah the emotional connection and
by emotional I don't mean I have to laugh or cry
all the time it's just that it resonates that
it makes them three-dimensional human and that
that your intuition says this is something that
a lot of humans could relate to right that I
it's just that's it's since writers are
usually very smart as as as a teacher as
an instructor used to tell me in grad
school the smartest people in the room
we have a lot of ideas and I don't mean that
in a good way ideas are are a problem because
you might get away with them and there's nothing
in you there it's just we have we have stored all
these ideas and like well what if the what
if the cops suddenly decides to rob the bank
sure sounds fun but what's what's in there that
you care about yeah why do you relate to that
because he's having a crisis about his identity
and his profession well now we're on to something
then it's not about robbing the bank it's
about what if a cop no longer believes in the
law because he thinks the system is crooked
I don't know I'm making this up okay that's
actually interesting tell me more so I feel like
yeah it's about finding your personal connection
okay so we we know some some cliche character
archetypes what about scenes what are some
things you see students do or maybe you did in the
beginning that they were too cliche whether it's
showing up at the best friend's wedding and you
know does anyone here object and then just what
the typical romantic comedy I would say scenes
about couples arguing tend to lead to a lot of
cliches especially if you just play them out
very dramatically and I'm not saying couples
don't have very dramatic arguments because they
do but what if you introduce certain elements in
there that makes suddenly a scene different and
I'm going to quote on this Phoebe Water Bridge
she said something that I loved and it blew
my she's such an amazing everything but she
said I always have to try to have three different
conflicts happening to the character at the same
time and they're all not of the same magnitude
so for example she needs to get an abortion it's
very hot in the room and she doesn't like how
her hair looks so she's trying to figure out or
tell her significant other that she needs to get
an abortion while checking herself in the mirror
while also noticing that she has sweaty armpits
so she writes comedy mostly so that I can see
how that can be a dramedy right it's very dramatic
but it's also very funny because she's distracted
so if the scene were just her saying we
need to talk I'm pregnant and I need to
get rid of the baby okay sure that can be a
compelling scene but it's also I don't know
if you play that way it's a bit conventional
but if she's concerned about her hair then
that sounds very human and she's seeing that she's
sweating yeah and she's wondering did the Barista
see me this sweaty and disgusting there's so many
options and she feels like oh my God I'm pregnant
I don't want to be pregnant I'm gross like Ugh
I've never felt so ugly I wish my hair was like
straight so sure think that's that's great advice
and it's your brothers [Laughter] I'm just saying
okay just that that would take the
cliche that would also spin it you
know what's interesting though that opens
up because I have this conversation this
morning about tone and I feel like tone is
such an important element in a story and
it's something I do think about right away even
though I can't I don't think I can avoid it tone
is really hard to Define what it is but you
recognize it right and most of the creators or
filmmakers we love have a very specific tone
like the coin Brothers have a very specific
kind of ironic sarcastic almost sometimes
almost depressing tone it's about plot it's
about character you don't really know
where it's at but it's you can sense it
and I was I was breaking down a story today
actually and I followed the story through
where it led me and at some point it led to a very
dark area that I got scared of and by the way I
would say getting scared of something is a good
sign because it says it means there's something
very personal to explore but at the same time
I felt it was so dark that it destroyed my tone
and I got worried I would lose my audience
that's one of those moments where you feel
like if I cringe and not in a an interesting way
maybe it's worth considering that direction and I
think it's a valid point sure so that you kind of
took it too far and it wouldn't work for the story
well I don't mind telling you what it
is because I'm not going to use it I
had I had a character with a situation and
she's trying to figure out how she feels
and why she feels so uncomfortable about what's
happening to her right and she doesn't know
which is it's odd it's not a story where it's
she's trying to get money and no the goal of
the characters to figure out why she feels the
way she feels right it's a situation triggered
a feeling and she doesn't understand it and it's
a very odd thing I don't know why I do this to
myself because it's not something tangible
first of all you got to be really careful do
I want to talk about this subject am I qualified
to talk about it does it actually resonate with
me or does it just sound like it would have an
impact and my gut feeling was like don't go there
don't go there because once you introduce
certain topics the story is done unless
you want to discuss the consequences of that
and I don't want to be the person doing that
and because I haven't been through it and hope
it doesn't happen to me and I gotta be respectful
but if my tone is kind of playful you got to be
really careful where you go some things are just
not going to be funny that's a good point no
matter how you approach it sure it's not funny
sure like the vibe is dead yeah yeah because
then you can't from that point on it can be
around comedy it can't be another element in your
story yeah you either make your story about that
because you actually will have something to
say or refrain from it but that that's want to
be really careful not everything is material for
storytelling unless like Michaela Cole who did I
may destroy you and the show is about that but she
went through it yeah yeah the only thing I could
think of is that if you showed the character's
life up until that point that was light and fun
and then if something horrible happens and then
how their life changes drastically after that
but yeah you can't continue but the story then
is about that and by the way I'm not against
horrible things happening to your character
I'm just saying their their boundaries to me
and there are things that I haven't experienced
that I'd rather not talk about what writing
process do you teach your students I try to
teach my students give them as many different
tools as possible I don't believe in any Darkness
I don't believe there's one single way to do it
when I teach so for example I have a whole class
for a three-hour class for structure and I give
give them all the approaches I know to structure
like the the save the cat approach to it the
Blake Snyder approach to it the eight sequence
structure whatever it's whatever helps they find
helpful to break so it's not so daunting to break
down story because we all feel it when you when
you're facing the story you're like oh my God
I have so much ground to cover and I don't know
so for example the eight sequence structure is
really helpful because you're thinking in terms
of 12 15 pages at a time so you're you're writing
shorts I'm talking about features of course
it's like writing short units and then by thinking
of units you're not thinking about the whole thing
with with TV well TV there is there are multiple
ways to do TV but I do give them I do compare TV
structure with film structure in the sense
that a drama pilot the end of the teaser
is usually the inciting incident the
end of act one is where it kind of gets
personal so the the end of act two would
be the midpoint in a 60 Minute 55 minute
pilot but I don't believe there's one way to
do things like whatever works for each person
do you ever find students challenge that because
they've they've read books before they've taken
your class or they've taken other classes and
they say well no this is actually how it's done
and they like those rules they like structure
do believe there should be structure they don't
usually question me because they understand that
I'm I'm very straightforward from the beginning
and I said look I'm going to give you everything I
know and sometimes there are different options but
I'm no they're adults so I'm giving them
an option it's like I'm not going to tell
you there's one single way to do it I'm going to
tell you all the ways I found out over the years
and some of my colleagues prefer this version
and others this one and it's my my role as an
instructor is to give them tools not to give them
the ultimate truth because there's no such thing
actually I would say the most important thing I
don't know if you can teach people how to write
you can teach them discipline you can encourage
them you can show them that it's not impossible
you can share experience experiences
that that reveal that you can get
frustrated and keep going you
can have failures and get up
it's amazing how many times everyone including
myself and everyone else we tend to think
that what happens to us is only happening to
ourselves and it's ridiculous because it's very
[Music] liberating to hear that other people have
gone through the same actually you don't all you
don't you never get you rarely get a chance but
if you can read first drafts by acclaimed writers
which of course you'll never find because
they don't want you to but Academy Award
writers winning writers also have awful first
drafts they also have scripts that don't work
it's it's not that they sit down and write the
most perfect script ever it takes many rewrites
so I know Aaron Sorkin will go on and say like
he wrote The Social Network in three months
and like maybe I don't know I'm sure he's
very talented and smart and qualified I'm
saying we all need time to get there this
is something that's hard for you students
to accept or or was that something for you
in the beginning that you just wanted to get
this idea out there these characters out there
you didn't want to have to do multiple drafts
um you mean if if they challenge the idea of of
rewrites sure or did you yourself challenge it
I well when I started out I had some resistance
to rewrites and it's important to understand that
when you resist it it's because you're scared
of it and I would say it is it is scary because
the first draft once you understand that the first
draft is not the final product it's just your
first approach to it then you understand that
the rewrites is where it actually gets tricky
and there are many ways to approach rewrites it
took me a while to learn how to do it as well
I usually use the image it's it's like a
wound it's a scar that you're reopening
and being very dramatic here but you finish the
draft and you're very pleased and you want to step
back right and take some distance and then you go
back to it and you have to reopen the wound like
it's all bloody again and then you have to stitch
it up again think that's when you need perspective
the most that's when you could use feedback from
close people conversations maybe even the help of
a script doctor at some point why not it's really
hard to have perspective on your own writing
sometimes you need some time to go buy maybe
weeks or a month before you dive in again
um and you need someone's perspective to know
what works and what doesn't and and maybe you
love a scene and that scene needs to go and you
need someone to tell you that scene needs to go
um the good thing about working
for hire or working with with
with people is that they actually give you notes
and I could spend hours talking about notes
themselves and sometimes they'll give you the
best notes and it hurts because you have to work
a lot on them but they're good notes you can tell
and sometimes you gotta find the note behind
the note some you don't you can't expect people
always to have the perfect note to give you
but it's your job to find out what they mean
um and also try to be very careful
when someone has one opinion
okay I'll see if I consider or not but when
one note keeps coming up over and over again
in different manners right but it's the same
note well then there's a problem right when
I a script I have to read right now that
I rewrote a couple of times it's a period
script and a note I kept getting back was
the main character is an [__] why do I care
and at first I resisted saying like no it's
the 60s that's how people did things back then
but then when I keep getting the same note
especially from female readers they're like
no that guy's an [__] well then I have
a problem because I'm not making a movie
for the 60s I'm making a movie for nowadays so
even though I'm trying to be very accurate in
terms of how I portray the period my audience
is now so I got to do something about it so
you had to make the character somewhat more
relatable and human to today's standards not
um 60s well he's a guy who's focused on on his
work and is is disregarding his he's very young
his wife is also very young and they have a baby
so instead of being a good father which he can't
because he's like he's too young he doesn't know
it's not how he means anything by it he just
doesn't know how to do it so he escapes family his
family's responsibilities by focusing on his work
and the note was he's being an [__] I'm like no
well he's a kid he doesn't know he shouldn't have
been a dad in the first place it's 60s back in the
60s you didn't share that responsibility they're
like no I don't care I don't care how good he
is at his job he left her alone to raise a child
and there's really no point in me arguing that
what about Don Draper well this is the thing
love Mad Men and I love Don Draper and I used
that as a reference Don Draper only works for
today's audiences because Jon Hamm is really
sexy okay that's fair enough yeah I remember
back when it came out I was watching it with
my girlfriend at the time and I would say he's
he's disgusting he's he's an awful person and
she would be like I don't care he's too hot
and what there's a point there I don't know how
that they got that that show made before casting
I think it took a while yeah he's awful he's
a broken man but he's John Hamm in a suit
you have read like hundreds of screenplays
correct when you've interned to these production
companies probably yeah what does that teach
you about writing and what came across your desk
it's the best advice I could give any writer
if you don't learn how to write read Scripts
Read Bad scripts which is what you'll
mostly do read good scripts as well but
there's no better way to write than reading
scripts see how different people use the language
on the format some people are more verbose
some people are very sparse in in descriptions
some people are really great scripts are not
literature they're not they have to be engaging
but they're not novels so if you can be very
concise and can convey the idea in a Snappy
way in one sentence those scripts really work of
course some people have great prose but they're
not there's not a great story there it's it's
so difficult because it's it's a conjuncture of
great story great characters great use of subtext
right there are many many scripts are marred by
the by characters just stating everything how
they feel and sometimes you got to do that but
using subtext good use of sub subtext it's
very it's always appreciated we most of the
time people are not we don't go through life
saying everything we feel or think actually
in order to avoid conflict we tend not to right
especially I was talking about couples couples
don't say everything to each other otherwise
they would break up or get divorced right away
so you make a scene about something else anyway
reading scripts helps you understand the format
and any doubts you might have about format
like how do I structure a phone conversation
well scripts that do that teach you use
of language how to be precise and concise
[Music] how to start scenes and end
them some people will just surprise you
every once in a while try to read great
scripts by recognized writers as well
the the script for unforgiving Clint
Eastwood's movie is that's a novel
I wouldn't use it as it's it's an amazing
script it's just the script itself is epic
I remember the script for Nightcrawler is an
amazing script the movie I don't I'm not that
crazy about but the script itself there's a use
of fonts in the script that was really original it
changes the size and type of font just to give you
an impression of La at night and the neon signs
and the descriptions in it are perfect that's
Nightcrawler is a perfect script to analyze at
least so read read reading bad scripts when you're
into an intern or production company and you read
bad Scripts it's it boosts up your your confidence
because you tell yourself I can do so much better
than this and this script not to talk bad about
anyone but I'm saying this script made it this far
especially I remember once I was shocked reading
a script that was terrible written in five minutes
and it had typos very important just check check
grammar and spelling typos are really distracting
and everyone will tell you this it shows it's
not everyone makes mistakes it's just typos
show that you don't care you didn't care enough to
check and you can even use software to check that
so reading scripts just it helps you tune
your mind into what it is writing a script
do you think most new writers are overly hard
on themselves or they have the opposite where
they think it's brilliant I think most
writers are really hard on themselves
of course you'll meet a few people
that will say they're brilliant
a I don't know if they actually believe it
and B if they actually believe that oh my God
they're don't envy them because they're gonna
hit their head against the wall at some point
I'm not saying people can't be brilliant of
course they're and they're in their Natural
Born storytellers I've met a few it's just
that don't I don't think it's a good idea
to go through life thinking you're brilliant
sooner or later it's gonna hurt it for all of us
but it hurts too to think you're not
brilliant and in fact you're the opposite so
I think we it's it would be good to avoid
extremes like at some point the the older
I get and I'm not really that old but the older I
get I realize what helps and what doesn't help and
what's useful is it useful to think I'm brilliant
no is it useful to think I'm an idiot no
is it useful to think that this is the best I I'm
doing the best I can and that it's probably going
to be good enough because this is what I can offer
and if they don't like it it's because maybe I
wasn't the right person for the project Maybe and
of course I say this very calmly now and then I'm
writing the script and I will say to myself like
oh my God this is awful I wish I could do better
and I will or I will also tell myself this is
my best writing and then you know what's funny
many times I thought I did my best writing and
no one connected with it and other times I had
a deadline and I wrote it very fast I thought oh
my God this is embarrassing and people loved it so
whatever opinion you have of yourself I wouldn't
I would try not to take yourself too seriously
in general in life I like that so you avoid
extremes because it also applies to dealing
with other people too oh no I'm very extreme
I'm saying what I wish I did try to I try to be
mindful about it I don't always succeed sure sure
we all want to sort of live in the gray but yeah
ideally if I could choose I would choose to be
aware as aware as they can it's in the moment as
I can and this has nothing to do with writing by
the way this is life I feel like there's so many
labels that I put on myself and then everyone
puts on one another and and you're meant to
categorize yourself and especially like what
do you write oh I write period dramas like well
that's not true that's what I'm doing now I
don't think that's what I'm gonna do forever
and it doesn't help I know they they need to
be able to label you so that they can hire
you and add it so I'm I'm not trying to
start a revolution like I am who I am but
if you have to label yourself to get a job to
it but internally I try not to label myself
I try to be a better writer every
day I try to expand my interests
and my scope and if someday I can write a
rom-com why not I don't know when you worked
at these production companies interning out
of the hundred screenplays how many were awful
uh I'd say about more than 90 percent are awful
or no I'm mean mean I'd say more than 90 are bad
maybe 40 are awful because you got to get people
credit really bad scripts don't necessarily make
it up the ladder because you got assistance
and their job is their Gatekeepers precisely so
what scripts are bad it doesn't necessarily
mean they're badly written it means that
they're conventional full of cliches
um maybe maybe they stick to genre
and and they don't transcend it
in any way lazy in terms of ideas
but it doesn't mean that doesn't mean they're not
potentially commercial products so I don't think
that people in charge of of choosing don't have
any taste or or can't discern what I think is that
they're trying to find something that sells and
if you check Netflix 10 most watched shows or
they're not necessarily good again I'm not trying
to be the judge of what's good or bad I mean
I try to be entertained but also stimulated
and I want to think and I want to feel
some people just need come back from work they
hate what they do and they want to watch something
that takes their mind off it and it works sure
and there are some networks that cater to that
and they're very predictable stories and outcomes
and and people feel safe in watching that that's
what they want it is look it is a business and
and I think most of the people involved in in
Show Business are very smart I'm I don't think
execs are bureaucrats I think they're some of
them went to Harvard and Yale and whatever and
they're really educated and smart it's just it's
a business so most of the shows big networks
are gonna put up are probably easy to digest
I I get it it's not what I watch but then
again I don't represent the larger population
that's a good point so the ones that were really
awful probably wouldn't have made it that far
in the process but you say 40 ish maybe we're
bad so then 60 were great or then there was a
gray area where some were not horrible no the
percentage of great scripts is really small
so great let's say good let's
say I'm generalizing let's say
between eight to ten percent of the scripts are
actually good great maybe two percent okay one
percent wow it's really hard to find a great
script it's really hard to write a great script
that's why certain I don't know Shauna Rhimes did
Gray's Anatomy it's what it's the 14th 15th season
of course then eventually she came up with other
shows but she's been work she was working on that
show for many years and that was one great
script that got it all started it's really
hard to replicate success some people The Simpsons
right yeah sure they did Futurama and some other
attempts but the Sims is all the Simpsons so
it's really really hard to write a great script
it's really hard to find the people willing
to take risks to produce it and get it made
Queen's Gambit big success what last
year it took 10 years to get that made
I remember meeting the the guy who wrote Dallas
Buyers Club that movie took 20 years to get made
I'm not saying that's okay and I'm not saying
that's the standard I'm saying you gotta be
ready to know that things take a long time unless
unless you want to go out there and make a really
small movie self-financed or through crowdfunding
or something like that which isn't easy either
and a lot of people do it and hope that it clicks
and can think of the examples where that helped
what's it called a woman walks home at night alone
yeah alone at night so she was at UCLA before
was in I don't remember the director's name Lily
Iranian so she went out there and made that movie
and it got an audience and she has a career and
yeah good for her yeah I'm poor or lily yeah yes
so a few examples like that but even back in the
day Sundance was like the way in and now Sundance
is so commercial and so oversaturated that if
you make a movie by yourself I don't even know
if you can find a spot there yeah it's probably
become a much different ball game and then some
of those movies then play other festivals
and it's kind of like all the same movies
going to these festivals and it's yeah I'm I don't
even want to get into the whole sure thing because
as a former film critic I know that world very
well sure and I have opinions about festivals but
yeah we can stay away get it no I think I think
that writing a good script takes a couple of
not even months I'd say a
year maybe two of rewrites
maybe know what what you want to say and then you
can get it done in six months I don't know would
you read every one of those screenplays from start
to finish when I when I had to read them yeah when
you're working as an intern at these Productions
ah yes yes I well first of all I had to
because when you do coverage coverage basically
exists so the people above you don't have to read
those scripts unless they have to so what you're
doing is you're summarizing you have to give them
a log line a synopsis maybe a short synopsis and
then a longer one of the story of the whole story
and then say the pros and cons and and and choose
if you're passing or considering or recommending
and of course everyone's really scared to
recommend because then your taste and your
job is on the line right so you got to
be re most of the times you'll say pass
and this because you really want to make sure
if you recommend something it's that good
I as an intern I did take chances
though and there were no consequences
but it it would happen that they would
come to me and say okay so tell me more
what did you see in it I want to hear you so
you got to have an opinion and by the way this
is really helpful as a writer it is but if if
you want to be an exec someday or a producer
you better have opinions and you better be
able to express them in an articulate way
um as a writer not so much I did it I
did it to learn mostly and get experience
so you were working with producers would they
also then read the script from back to front or
if you can if you suggest they consider it or
even if you recommend it maybe not themselves
their assistants will I don't know necessarily
but you're basically saving them time um
but if you waste their time you won't be there
much longer because if they had to read and hate
it and this is it's part of the business sure
what if your tastes are just edgier and you
like something that's more of an art film and
they're looking for a feel-good relationship
story well I would say is if you're entering on
a company do your research on their mandate so if
they do horror and you're and and they get for
any number of reasons a romantic story with no
horror whatsoever because you never know and maybe
maybe the the son of someone they know wrote the
script and sent it I don't you never know how that
works it's not for them it's not their mandate
unless you can ask them like hey I got the script
it's really weird it's not really your mandate
do you want me to go on with it and they'll say
yes please read it anyway I see so you're going
to check if something is not sort of in their
wheelhouse you'll check with them you should be
yeah so Blum House right that's horror everyone
knows that so if you have a Thriller with spies
it might be a great script it's probably not
and by the way blood house doesn't spend more
than three to five million per movie so you're
going to do your homework they're not the right
company for it maybe it's a great script and
you tell them hey by the way this is not your
mandate but it's a great script okay we'll send
it over to our friends somewhere else and they
always a favorite I don't know but it makes
you look good to know what their mandate is
sure sure but if you're recommending stuff
that's just then they're gonna sit you down and
why are you sending us it didn't
happen to me I'm just imagining sure
you got to know what your role is as well and
as an intern you don't have a lot of power
how many of the screenplays that
you read went on to be films
less than 10 probably supplement is a thing
some of them knew were already going to get
made some of them you knew you knew they
were going around town so it's not like
only the production company had that script
and you could tell I remember there was a
script about the Kelly gang in Australia
that movie was obviously ready to get shot
it was so I don't even know what they they made me
read it maybe because they wanted to invest in it
but it didn't feel like someone sent
that on spec that was ready to go
I'm trying to remember there were amazing scripts
I read that didn't get made and I'm surprised
oh which which script I read and I haven't seen
the movie yet the one with Michael Keaton worth
that just came out recently about the 911 lawyer
I read that script oh yes that was great so I read
that script in 2016. I just watched that and
they just got right he got made 2020 I think
right yeah that was so two four to five years
that's not that bad actually but it takes a while
so you said there were a few that were excellent
that didn't get made yeah I'm I'm trying to
remember I remember an amazing script about
Anne Frank and the woman in New York who got
the book published for the first time in the
40s I think or maybe early 50s so how the the
manuscript was discarded at first and this this
junior editor a woman who she wanted to become
an editor the woman who discovered the book and
said hey wait a minute this is actually relevant
that script I remember reading it and I
got very emotional about it and that's
really hard to do it's really hard to
get an emotional reaction from a script
if you're gonna make people laugh that's good
that's a lot if you can make people teary-eyed
wow that's very unique I remember that script
very well because I was at work I was just I was
about to break into tears and I'm like I'm in
an office I shouldn't I shouldn't be crying in
public they're gonna ask me if something's wrong
at home like that's the script it's just so good
um no I have tons of respect for that writer
and it was never made not that I know
off but sometimes it takes 10 years
um hopefully it gets made how do you like
to create characters so when when you're
when it's based on real people the challenge is
to understand who they are beyond the obvious
meaning and you'll see this with biopics
it's such a especially when they don't
work right it's I don't want to get the public
Persona because I can find that on YouTube um
um especially on if it's indulgent and yeah
mostly lazy self-conscious so I'm not going
to talk bad criticize any biopics but it's like I
already knew that that's an actor playing that guy
but I want to see what happens backstage I want
to see what happens when they're alone I want
to see who they were before they were well known
or confident about themselves I want to see what
they do when yeah when the world is not watching
so with the Chicago script actually got a chance
to talk to the guy who was based on and that was
a that was a big that was a big challenge in there
because he was a he was a revolutionary
and think he still is a revolutionary
so when he read my script of course you don't you
never adapt reality exactly as it is you gotta
change it up a bit and you get adapted for it to
be a story because reality is chaos stories have
a structure right and you got you gotta fudge
the facts a little bit not too much ideally
so he wanted it to be like a documentary so
he basically called me all sorts of names
we had a great relationship until
he read the script and he was like
no you didn't write it exactly as I told
you I'm like well that's not a story
anyway that's neither here nor there but what
you're trying to understand the person how they
see the world their contradictions how how they
are three-dimensional people when you're making up
characters it's not that difference in the sense
that you're trying to find in your own database
attitudes that resonate and that
would build a possible individual
and some just filter in there when you're writing
as I said when you write a a couple fighting
or or a daughter a mother and daughter
fight or father and son fight whatever
it's hard not to think of your own experience
either intentionally or unintentionally so
um there are guiding questions you can use
always I remember there was a there was like
a six question questionnaire that Neil Landau
gave me at UCLA again I had great instructors
at UCLA and people who still talk to and it
was basically the questions were like What's
what's the trait that most that you like least
about yourself it was like introspection questions
but then how to apply that to character like
what's your crutch what's your strength what's
um so again when I when I teach character on UCLA
they're I give them multiple techniques ask all
the possible questions observe there's an exercise
that make them do where it's like eavesdrop people
don't be creepy but when you go to the supermarket
eavesdropping conversations and see how people
relate to one another just in terms of
dialogue right notice how some people
don't finish their sentences notice how
the euphemisms what they avoid saying
notice what they actually say and
what's implied with their body language
observate observation is always
the key to character and dialogue
walking down the Santa Monica strand you'd pick
up fantastic conversation and you don't even have
to eavesdrop you're just there and people yeah
they're not even they're not even concealing
what they're just saying about I'd say anywhere
in L.A studies the truth is if you're a curious
person you'll find characters anywhere it
doesn't have to be La it can be any town
just notice how people are very specific about
how they present themselves I always say this
to to my students when they have to pitch like
remember that you're not it's not just your words
it's how you present yourself they've already
started judging you when the moment you came in
so choose how you're gonna dress for that
meeting how you're going to present yourself
just because now that they're they're paying
attention right the same thing with the characters
is that how do they dress do they care about how
they look do they care about appearances do they
not how do they feel about aging do they care
if they're wrinkled or do they not care at all
are they overcompensating exactly aging do
they have any physical issues that affects
their personality not per se what I'm
saying is that affects the personality
usually there's a connection sure yeah or are
they always another thing is someone that's
always bragging about themselves
that that's speaks volumes yeah
well that's it's always that's why I like
to have characters intimate moments because
it's very your persona and your actual self are
very different how many people are depressed and
we don't know it that's right and now thankfully
we're talking about it in public but even now
I'm trying to be honest with you but there's a
part of me that this is my Persona we can't help
it I'm doing the same thing I'm doing my best to
be myself but just even here yeah when you're in
front of other humans your behavior changes and
you don't behave the same way in front of your
family your loved ones your friends your enemies
that's true the cops you're just someone else
the Checker at the you you're happy hey how was
your day oh great hey oh everything's we have
so many masks yeah so many masks did you catch
that game the other night oh it was great yeah
all right well you take it easy if you go to
the DMV you're gonna try to be really friendly
because that those people hate being they hate
their jobs and I don't blame them so you're like
hey it's beautiful whatever I don't know how
do you find out what a character wants I guess
I guess it has to be something
that I'm interested in um
sometimes character will come
out of the wand comes first
the quest comes first and then it's not always
the same it's always different but sometimes
you want to explore a certain Quest
and then you wonder who would be the
most interesting person to me in this
quest in this Mission so is it the most
adequate person or is it the most or really a fish
out of water so I have a thing where I tend to
have characters on a spiritual or yeah abstract
quests and it's it's really an issue I don't
make it easy on myself they don't want material
things I've managed to figure this out over time
um and I've I've had some problems with
people like what's their goal I don't get it
it's like she won't she's trying to
become this or he's trying to understand
with Leary he's like he's trying to find he
promised Harvard the the future of psychology
a new method and that's why he got hired and he
doesn't know what that is so and his students
hate him and if he doesn't find that method
he promised them he's going to be out of a job
a widower without a job at 40 with two kids and
by 40 1960 40 year old not today being to 40 years
nothing it's nothing but in 1960 Don Draper was
36. so if you were 40 you were old so he's he's
trying to find something and he doesn't know what
it is and I like those sorts of challenges it does
it does turn me into somewhat of an intellectual
writer I guess because I'm pursuing ideas
um but that's okay if I guess if the day I want to
write a script about people pursuing money I can
it's always easier if what they want is a
loved one or money because it's tangible
what if it's the idea that they think money will
I mean what what if it's this elusive care that
that okay they get the money but then it doesn't
fix what they thought it would fix oh but I think
that's inevitable that's the thing it's the thing
with the want and the need right so they want
money but they need to change the way they're
approaching life in general I don't know so it's
this idea that before the midpoint there's a
want and after the midpoint it's about the need
and movies are usual there's a moral element to
movies Hollywood movies at least which is they
were trying they were trying to be the biggest
investors in Wall Street and it's actually
about finding someone who loves you
this is a class evening we've seen
this over and over and over again right
he thought he was after the job
and he was actually after love
but it's easier if you say it's a
movie about people desperate for money
of course when you actually watch
the movie it's not about that
the want is usually not doesn't Define what the
movie's about and the reason why this works it
might sound schematic but the reason why it works
is that that's how people actually are we we
there's a lot of denial I feel like in everyday
life and we tell ourselves we want thing and we
don't really know what we want or we what
we need first movies do that in 90 minutes
or two hours but in life you realize years
later that I was pursuing I thought I wanted
to make it big in Hollywood I actually wanted
to I don't know heal my wounds from the past
if it rings a bell it's because a lot
of people are going through that sure
well a lot of people that go into entertainment
sure there's interesting things that drive them
incredibly happy satisfied people don't need
to tell stories you don't think so there was
there's nothing dramatic about it and I feel
like no I'm not saying we should be miserable
Let Me Clear clarify this I don't think we all
should be tortured and and sad I'm saying that
movies need a certain dramatic element now
element of conflict no one wants to see a
movie about two people who are perfectly in love
all the time that's true I'm not I'm not trying
to be dogmatic what I'm saying is that we you
need events and this and then but it can be and
and has to be like but however and so I don't know
personally feel like the need to express yourself
comes from something that you need to understand
something that you're lacking something that
you could say the same for
someone who writes a piece of code
they're creating something there's an Artistry to
that code sure I've never written code so I can't
talk about that I any anytime you create something
is because you feel like something's missing right
that's what I'm saying like you're not it
doesn't come from a place of total satisfaction
um I'm not saying there should be
something missing in your life and
if you've got any if whoever gets to a
point where they feel totally satisfied
man I'm sure that's awesome I'd
love to be there but I feel like
the second you you become enlightened and
at peace with the universe and everything
I don't know why I would sit down and write a
script I'd be just I'd be basking in existence not
not to get too philosophical and a bit and again I
don't mean that you have to be a tortured Soul no
I'm sure the people that write the classic come
back home for the high school reunion and and it's
all in a neat package and it turns out everything
works out okay that that's not that's different
than somebody who writes about scamming investors
on Wall Street or something there's a different
different mindset there maybe I don't
know there's room for everyone look
this is the thing the the audience again
I think the audience is smart so if you if
you have a movie or a story where a family is
totally at ease and they're all happy together
after probably 10 minutes or 15 the audience is
gonna be like something's gonna happen something
something's bad it's going to happen and then
half hour goes by and they're like wait when's
something gonna happen and then an hour goes by
and they're perfectly happy eating peanut butter
sandwiches and you're like what am I watching
there's nothing happening right so that's even
if you want to write a perfectly happy Story the
audience is expecting something some conflict
um and and I don't I don't feel conflict is
something artificial that you insert into the
story life is full of conflict like out there it's
just you're stuck in traffic that's conflict yeah
it's not someone died but you're like oh my God I
can't get to I wait I can't wait to get out of my
car and I've been in traffic for a half an hour
and I got to use the restroom and oh my God I'm
gonna get home and I haven't bought food for
the cats that's conflict all the time I think
you've said that good writing demands honesty
and a large degree of emotional involvement
yeah I certainly believe it I think it's
the most difficult part of the equation
um there's certain Concepts like
honesty or Freedom that I know
what it is but I can't Define like what is honesty
I feel like when you're being honest and that's
why intuition is such an important part of it
you only you can know that you can and you you
got to be honest first of all with yourself
and that's why I question the notion of
idea so much which is I had a great idea
is it honest [Music] does it resonate does it
tingle no then let it go of course it's if you
can have a lot of ideas that's great we all do but
it's just is this the story I want to tell is this
what I want to talk about right now and I'm
talking strictly from if you have a choice
right again if you're if you're hired you've got
to find your honesty within that material because
it's first and foremost a job right you're an
artist but you're getting paid to do something
so if you have a write-up you gotta
write a procedural well find your honesty
and make it work without within that
frame but if you're writing your own story
we're we're all constantly changing right and
we're not the same person we were two or five
years ago so what you're going to be interested
in now or what resonates is not going to be the
same thing and that's the problem sentence with
rewrites which is you wrote the script at a
certain point in your life and then maybe you
have to rewrite to rewrite it two years later
and you're in a different point in your life so
it's really hard because you have to reconnect
with that emotional State and maybe maybe you
wrote that script when you were getting a divorce
and you were heartbroken and it was so raw and
so real and now two years later you've gotten
over your divorce and you're perfectly content
by yourself and you're like oh my God I gotta
go through that again and and it is part of the
challenge you get through it through craft I guess
you go to the memory bank of emotions but
because it's not like it's not like you have
to be in a constant state of emotional turmoil
right actually that's the worst thing to write
but you you must have gone through the experience
to know that it's real and that what it feels like
so if I if you ask me to describe what honesty
is I don't really know but I know what I'm being
honest and it it takes courage and it takes
and it's exhausting you got to tell yourself
this is not truthful when I'm writing it's
good writing sure I'm a good writer but this
is not the story I gotta tell or I can do better
than this or I gotta dig deeper right now this
morning I was working I'm rewriting something
and wrote a pretty decent first draft let's see
and I sent it to the right people the people
I trust and they gave me great feedback great
very very profound and they said you gotta be
careful because you did a good job but this is
a bit superficial you gotta dig deeper if you
don't want this to be a bit lame you gotta dig
deeper and this is now what the story is about
like your story is not what you what you're
saying it's about it's not really about that so my
honesty there is to say they're absolutely right
and I had a vague feeling about it and they're
telling me that and I gotta listen to it
so the challenging thing is so this morning I
didn't just sit down and write I had to figure
out okay how do I dig deeper why do I want what do
I want to say and no one can tell me that you got
to figure out yourself right you can ask friends
but they're not gonna have the answer because only
your materials so I've been trying meditating
and I'm new at it so I don't really know how to
do it but it's just like closing your eyes taking
deep breaths and trying to go deeper within and
see if something comes out of that like
what do I actually want to say through this
and it's that process of being patient with
yourself but also don't get don't get distracted
be patient but don't do like 10 minutes and
move on to something else because it's very easy
oh I have to answer some emails no no no no no
don't get distracted take the time figure it out
so I don't yeah it's it's I don't know what
the answer is I know that you you get a first
and foremost be honest with yourself and
you went to people for feedback who didn't
totally just gush over it they but then
they didn't rip you apart so they gave you
this is great but I need you to go deeper there's
more to this this is just skimming the surface
their feedback confirmed that they were
the right people to give it to and they
identified the problems that I suspected
myself without me having to say it [Music] um
and they gave me the right amount of validation
and said it's not that far away you're not it's
closer than you think but this is one of the best
feedback I got actually was you're missing a part
of the equation so this this this guy and I
wanted I wanted to be the producer he said
well I don't know how to explain it
without I'm not a reveal the whole
story but it doesn't matter what I'm saying
is there's an object that produces an emotion
in someone right and she's trying to understand
why she's reacting the way she is to the object
and this guy said it's not about the object you're
making it about the object and the answer is that
there's something happening in her life before
the object comes into it and she's not aware of
it she thinks our marriage is perfect she
thinks her professional life is perfect
and what the object does is reveal that it's
actually not as great as she thought so the
object itself doesn't mean that much yeah sure
you can explore what it is but it put it it causes
if if her life is like a pawn it's the stone
that causes the ripple effect so I'm like mind
blown yes yes good point it's missing emotional
impact because I haven't done that part of work
so it's an object that reveals an unraveling
I was making it about the object itself
and that's too cerebral it's like no you can then
figure out why the object has that effect on her
but it's not about that it's about herself
and how little she actually knows herself
and how that the whole thing unravels and
she realizes wait a second do I actually
love my husband I thought I did does he
actually know me do I know myself my job
I thought it was so stable and and this
woman who is this woman my mentor yeah
which is an interesting script to write
but it's it's it's hard it's not as easy as
yeah they want to win the tournament can they make
it can they get to the finals that's another story
that's a progression here the progression
is not as clear you got to figure out okay
it starts off with the object it
ends with her discovering herself
I gotta fill out the wrist what's the journey
um and there is no clear-cut answer only
each person has their own way to answer that
um see but that's talking about challenges that's
a challenge this script is driving me crazy
why did I put myself in this position well I guess
because don't know it's what I have to write right
now and that's what you were talking about maybe
earlier is just getting lost in the story and all
great writers will go through that maybe just
because yeah it's not going to be clear-cut
well this is the thing sometimes you come up
with an idea and I don't know how commercial
what I'm writing this thing is but this is
one of those scripts I'm writing for myself
because it's almost the end of the year and I
can I've while I'm waiting for a contract to come
through I'm like I'm gonna write this now if you
want to be more commercial of course you can't be
that you got to be more grounded I guess so you
can find references and always tell my students
steal still not in terms of content still
in terms of structure right find comps
find movies that are similar to yours and break
down the structure not the not what we actually
see I'm not saying Steel character steel
dialogue no that's awful what I'm saying is
your movie similar to Wes Anderson's style then go
check out the Royal tenor mountains and see okay
scene one character a says this thing to character
B scene two so the structure how does it evolve
and then you can fill out that structure with
your own ideas and this is this is the history
of art right because you're not really stealing
because it will never resemble that work because
by stealing it it's becoming yours and the whole
history of filmmaking and and storytelling works
that way right Shakespeare was stealing from the
Greeks it's fine because you're not stealing the
essence you're stealing the structure so I do
that all the time I look for comps I study the
structure especially if they're great I'll see
what they do even the subplots I'm like look they
have this subplot interesting was it necessary
I don't know but it's great it adds flavor to it
um yeah what do I need what don't
I need what can I get rid of
what was the structure of Nightcrawler
um Nightcrawler for example it's it's a very
it doesn't innovate in terms of structure it's
it's a very clear progression it's about
a guy living in the margins of society
he's not even a part of society and
he's there's something off about him
so it's how he takes advantage of a crooked
system to escalate in it until exploiting
and the flaws in it it's interesting because he
has no Ark so in terms of structure it's actually
it's if you if you check this it's very easy
to recognize the inciting incident of the First
Act break the midpoint the low point it's it's
it's almost it's external almost it's obvious
because the movie's not about that the
movie is obviously about escalation
what's interesting is that this guy the hero is
an anti-hero and he doesn't have an arc so usually
it's desirable for characters to have an arc to
learn something so to say to change to evolve
this guy since he is a sociopath and it's
it's really hard to identify with him
but he's also a victim of the system he doesn't
change and it's how he ends up winning so it's a
very pessimistic story it's a movie about how
this awful guy finds his Niche and exploits
it and his people around him and yeah makes a
lot of money and doesn't pay the price for it
um but the structure it's it's very easy
to copy or or borrow from because it's
just the beats keep escalating what about
the Rene Russo character does she have an arc
she has a little bit more of an arc I think
it's a descending Arc in the sense that she
doesn't get any better she actually succumbs to
this guy's ambition like never-ending ambition
she's a bit more human in that sense
it's it's a weird movie because it's
it kind it kind of feels like a movie with a
message and movies with a very strong message
it's not very dramatic to have a very strong
message like movies shouldn't be a vehicle for ex
exposing an idea no no again I don't mean to
say how things should be it's just that you
don't want to be didactic you don't don't like
movies that tell me what how to feel or think
I like when we start to contradict
me or make me question my own beliefs
and Nightcrawler in a in a weird way gets away
with that I don't feel like they're lecturing
me but it's about like look how awful the
society is right like look how obsessed
and addicted we are to the news cycle that
even this guy producing news is well received
um I don't know look I'm I might be
wrong about this because I'm thinking
about Network speaking of that back and and
back in the day 1976 I think and network has
a very strong message and I love it so I
guess it's all a matter of how you do it
we hear a lot of writers say that it's
impossible to pitch their story ideas to Netflix
recently you pitched a show to Netflix is that
correct no didn't recently pitch a show to Netflix
don't have the experience of pitching to Netflix I
pitch two other networks or or streaming services
I've I've had meetings at Netflix and
they were very cordial I would say but
I'm curious what what do they say about
what makes it so impossible to pitch well
maybe that it's closed that you'd have to have
someone quote walk you in because it's so sought
after and that would make sense that there's a
barrier to entry especially now because yes so
before you could just pitch with with a log line
or a proposal or something I think with Netflix
now you need to have for sure a script and maybe
two if it's a show maybe two episodes written
yeah sure so Netflix doesn't need that much
content they they have a lot of sources to get
it from or they even buy already produced content
and they they recently bought a couple of movies
that I was surprised like Mexican movies like a
cop movie and prayers for the stolen which is the
Mexico entry for the Oscars and I was pleasantly
surprised because I thought wow those are actually
interesting choices I don't know who they have
in mind a cop movie love Alfonso rip Palacios the
director but it's a very odd choice for Netflix
like who who are they who's their target audience
but then again I don't know how much they paid
for it so maybe it's not a significant investment
you said you did go to Netflix to at least
yeah I remember a meeting I had on Netflix
and I was actually surprised this was 2019. I was
surprised how aware they were of International
shows This was before this this latest Trend where
the squid game is an international phenomenon and
some of those Spanish shows like a money Heist so
there's been a big change in the last two or three
years in terms of American audiences opening up to
foreign content and then parasite and winning the
Oscar and suddenly people reading subtitles and I
don't mean just in La not because of course La is
very Cosmopolitan but so when I met with them they
were seeing that was going to happen it was the
beginning of something and they were very aware
of shows in Argentina and Brazil and South America
which was interesting so that
was the impression I got that
we were getting into and I think we're right in
the middle of that where it doesn't matter where
the content is produced as long as it's good and
I think the squid game is I'm not talking about
the quality of the show which I think is pretty
decent I'm not a big fan but it's original and
people don't care if it's good they'll watch it
yeah so how did you get your meeting at Netflix
um so I was involved in a fellowship
called tomorrow's filmmakers today
where I met mostly for for Latino filmmakers and
I met a bunch of other colleagues that some that
ended up playing a really important role in
my life friends colleagues and that's how we
got a meeting at that time we got meetings with
different places with HBO with Netflix with Disney
um and they really and it was they received you
with a ceremony and everything like it was a
big deal and it's good because even though it's
it's it's not easy to get anything picked up by
them it's good to know that they're there and that
you're part of that environment right and then the
thing about being in La is that it's all happening
there you can just go into the Hollywood offices
and it's that Netflix is around the corner I
haven't pitched them yet though but I'm open to it
so you were there as a group with with other
individuals who were all yeah we all got a
chance to talk to them so it wasn't a big group
so the chance to get to know them and and meet and
yeah it was great what did you
bring with you to the meeting
um well I didn't get a chance to show them my
script but I did talk about what I was working
on and my previous experience and there's
so much about it that's not just what you
write but who you are and this cell people
are just also investing in you I feel like
your previous experience your background your
interests your passions and if you're if they
want to spend time with you so it's just a matter
of introducing yourself and telling this is what
I write this is what I do this is what I like this
is my my plan what does it mean to be bold I think
you said something where you you have to be bold
to make it in Hollywood what does bold mean yeah
I'm laughing because again make it in Holly it's
the expression that said it but it makes me cringe
because make it it's like what is making it and
the more time I spend here the less I know what
it means it's like to get yeah to get paid I guess
to do something you love you gotta be bold in the
sense that you got to put yourself out there and
it's really hard and we all struggle with it which
is sometimes we feel like we're more comfortable
in a place that's not really comfortable which is
I'd rather not go to that event or that screening
or I'd rather stay home and watch TV because it's
so hostile and all that and sometimes you gotta
show up you got to send those emails and the thing
with emails or or texts if you have the phone
number and you have a relationship sometimes they
don't you don't get replies you you get rejections
people ignore you they don't get back to you you
think you're gonna meet and the meeting gets
canceled so being bold is being persistent being
getting out of your comfort zone because your
comfort zone is not really comfortable you think
it is I'm I tell this to myself every day I think
I'm a writer what do I do what I know how to do
is to write and well no that's not it because you
can be an amazing writer and no one will notice
and it's hard learning to put yourself out
there is hard and sometimes surround yourself
with friends who do it and learn from them I've
hate it but I had to teach myself go out to that
event meet people follow up friends that can
get you into things tell them can you get me
into that event and and you meet people of course
then you gotta have something to show and all that
be nice to everyone invite them ask
ask them out for a coffee or drinks
um at some point things will start moving by
themselves the other thing I noticed with time
no one likes to read scripts so I've been thinking
of directing something myself I'm actually writing
something I want to direct because people don't
like reading but they're like watching so even
if you don't get into Sundance or whatever it's
something to show and I think the best way to make
something is not thinking about the result but
just doing it because you feel like you have to
so there's not one single way to do it this is
what I'm doing right now and hopefully it pays off
and I know you said earlier that the term making
it makes you cringe and get why that would be but
do you think the longer that you're here or that
we are here in this town or in the industry that
the term making it the needle moves so it's like
this spectrum and and making it when you first
got here would be one thing but then after you've
been here a long time you realize no there's not
really a making it because it's then one project
into the to the next and that idea of success it
just keeps moving there's a carrot that you can't
grab I think I think it's healthy to demystify
the the idea I think it was Gertrude Stein they
used to say there's no there there in the sense
that one thing that has been helpful living here
is realizing that that I aspire to is here that
I got a chance to meet in Vegas Tom Cruise right
oh nice and it was just we were just two guys in
a room sure he's a mega star and whatever and
his everything shines about him but the fact
that I can have access to that guy and he and we
can talk means that it's not a different world
it's funny when I back in my country in Argentina
and people ask me like so what's Hollywood like
I'll say well it's mostly a bunch of people
in offices it's not glamorous sure you go to
the Emmys or the Oscars or whatever and they're
glamorous but the rest of the year there's still
a lot of people in offices saying yes no yes no
do we have the money do we want to spend the money
and then going on shoots and shooting anything is
not glamorous at all so it takes a long time takes
a lot of waiting this is the thing no one talks
about like movies are glamorous no movies are not
glamorous events are glamorous shooting a movie
is strenuous it's exhausting can be frustrating
[Music] that's why actors have trailers
because they have to wait you gotta sit up
and then when you're in development
you're meeting in office is having coffee
and a lot of times it's just saying no because
it's from their side the exact side it also takes
courage saying no is easy you don't waste money
saying yes well that's where it actually starts
um I don't know I guess we're all here
because we think that it's possible
it's possible to do what we want and get paid
for it it's possible to make a career out of it
and when you're here the truth is think about
this often is I gotta remind myself there are
more things in life than a career of course
I gotta pay rent and that's a big concern
I gotta make a living ideally I can have
enough money to also buy other things and
eventually sent my kids to college and
all that but we get so obsessed the whole
the whole struggle here the hustle you get
obsessed with it's all about work and I'll
work 24 hours a day if I have to in weekends
it's like no what's the point especially if
you do something creative it's really hard to do
something creative if all you're doing is working
um you gotta find some balance or try at
least if you have no choice I get it but
it can all be about work all the time and
making it it's not sustainable I see I see
very young people who are exhausted again because
I want to talk about the back side as well like
people who are actually doing really well
and are stressed out and are exhausted and
are not sleeping like you gotta sleep you
gotta eat anyway when you tell your friends
in Argentina that it's Hollywood is really a
lot of people in offices what's their reaction
[Music] I guess some people ignore me because
they want to keep thinking whatever they want
to think people who are in the film industry
there which is it's barely an industry it's way
smaller there's a lot of production but I think
they find that interesting encouraging they're
like oh really that makes sense or they ask me
do you go to the beach or I say rarely I don't
I forget there's a beach yeah I'm a writer I'm
just I think it's every time you reveal something
The Backs the backstage or the back flip of
something people imagine it's always interesting
nothing nothing's as glamorous
or as exciting from the inside
um it's a good point hopefully the
writing itself is exciting you know
the other thing I always say is a lot of
the times the people in charge the people
have the power don't know what they want
until they see it so if you get rejected
it doesn't mean your script is bad or it does it's
not worth it it's all very subjective it's very
easy to get discouraged when you get turned down
in contests or fellowships and you're like oh my
God I'm awful I'm not good enough maybe maybe
they they were just looking for something else
I was a finalist for example one of NBC's
writing programs I was a finalist and I
did really well in that interview and I didn't
get it and they told me it's don't take it too
hard themselves they said it's like we had
to pick I don't know six seven people so I
didn't I said what I could have been one of them
it's just it's also a matter of luck and context
this project you want to that you're writing
to direct do you plan on shooting it here in
the states no I'm actually it's interesting
I I'm writing that to shoot in Argentina for
several reasons because I'm I'm setting it down
there and also to be perfectly honest because the
exchange rate is really beneficial so if you have
dollars right now you can you can do whatever you
want in Argentina all right and toddles go a long
way again not to imply that I'm going to exploit
my fellow countrymen because I intend to pay
really good salaries but it makes a difference
the currency fluctuates a lot there yeah
inflation is a really big inflation [Music] um
but again you can you can get a
an amazing crew and equipment and everything
and really qualified people and actors and
um and it's also a great way for
me to reconnect with my own country
it's not just a Financial Choice it's just that I
Really Wanna reconnect with yeah with the language
and and the culture and the stories down there
how does a writer gain confidence in their voice
I guess the best way to get gain confidence in
your own voice is to practice practice explore
make sure that it feels right sometimes
your voice and car incorporates things
from other writers and that's okay because we
all we're all influenced like you'll say like
I want to be more of a Hemingway sort of
writer it doesn't mean that you're going
to be like Hemingway it's just that
there's a certain musicality to it or
I think with time and practice eventually and by
trying to enjoy the process your voice comes out
it's not one of those things that you can force
you can't you can't fake it because sooner or
later you'll get exhausted it just feels right it
feels like something you would say it feels like
this is how I express myself there's a little
bit of self-consciousness in it but also you want
to surprise yourself you don't want to just
get stuck in one idea of what your voice is
do you think it's easier to write in a fictional
name like a nam to plume just because you can
then express yourself more without the worry
of judgment interesting I've never done it
maybe I should I I've thought about it actually
admire writers musicians who preserve their
identity I know in some cases we know who they are
with Elena Ferrante for example the Italian writer
who now has there's an HBO show and and Maggie
Gyllenhaal actually adapted another novels I'm
seeing her but we don't even know if it's a woman
we don't even know if it's one person several
people if it's a man there are many theories about
that I think it's fun but it's very interesting
how that whoever did that whoever writes those
novels it goes it's counterintuitive to our idea
of ego and recognition and success right it's
like wow you took the time to write all that
brilliantly and you don't want any credit
for it because you have a fake name
I don't know maybe that's the way to go the same
thing with with bands I recently saw the residents
who have been playing together for 50 years
and nobody knows who they are they wear masks
I should try it and maybe
there's something liberating
and then there was a Spanish female author
correct that we find out we found out there
were two male writers that were sort of embodying
this woman maybe I'm getting the country wrong
that rings a bell don't know exactly I know that
at some point I think Woody Allen who you can't
quote anymore jokingly said that Shakespeare
was actually Four Women maybe I don't know I
do know I will say this on a more serious note
there's something to be said about collaboration
we haven't touched up on this but I think about
it often I love collaboration it's really hard to
find someone to collaborate with again it's it's
almost like a romantic relationship you gotta
understand one another and share certain interests
and certain Dynamics that's why so often it's
siblings who do it like the Coen brothers or the
Duplantis brothers or but there's something about
collaboration that's just so much fun and there's
immediate reassurance that you're on to something
the only issue it has is that for the industry
they want to label you as a team so it's they
want to Market you that way so it's really hard
to collaborate on one project and then break that
Society what are the tools a beginning writer has
to learn in order to write for film and television
um I think that the first thing to do is watch
a lot of films and TV read a lot of scripts
um certain books can help but mostly I'd say if
you read a script start breaking down Scripts
okay study the format study how they use dialogue
how they describe study characters and how they're
presented it's very important to have to have
strong character presentations the way you
introduce them how is it effective how do we
know that's the protagonist reading scripts
is the best way for sure and and watching a lot
and maybe reading the script and then watching
how it was made what gets lost what they removed
from the final version of the story reading a lot
and writing that's really the only way to learn
how to write is to write and write and write and
write and write and get all the bad scripts out
of the way first we all have those fat Scripts
um and after a while they get better and by by
studying other people's writing and asking for
feedback you get better you've mentioned
that you love Paul Thomas Anderson when
you look at his scripts and then you
watch the films what stands out to you
PT Anderson is a freak of nature I adore him I am
I love him deeply I recently saw his last movie
and I he was there to introduce it such a pleasure
to hear him talk he's so articulate and so
real I think both PT Anderson and Tarantino
who many people have they compare in many ways
first of all because they're both originally
from La which is a rarity in itself it's weird
they have an authority to speak about
the city because they were born here but
they're both amazing writers and this doesn't get
said enough I feel like people talk about them as
directors and they're amazing directors some of my
favorite but they're also incredible screenwriters
Tarantino is an amazing screenwriter he has a
sense of timing and he's become so much more
sophisticated with time ptenders I think what
I admire is there's an energy to what he does
it's not even a quality of the story itself his
characters have this sense of urgency no matter
that if you watch his movies they're always like
pulsating take There Will Be Blood Daniel Lee
Lewis or Adam Sandler and punch drunk love or
in Magnolia or in this last one characters his
characters almost run they can't keep still
they have to get their they have an anxiety
and I feel like that's the most distinctive thing
but also he never makes the same movie twice all
his movies are so different in genre and tone and
aesthetic and he shoots with different cameras and
textures and colors he's just
it's one of those guys who's
he emanates Cinema see I don't even try to
imitate him he's just in a whole different League
that's what I was wondering when your students
ask you I want to become the next and then
fill in the blank do you have advice for them
where don't actually try to emulate that style
I would never tell them what what to do I my
advice would probably be try to be yourself
or sure why not try to be the next BT Anderson
the odds are you're going to be the next you
there's only one PT Anderson and we should
be grateful he exists but this I can say the
same thing about Lady Gaga what I'm saying is
it's great to have role models we all do but
at the end of the day you're not going to be
them you're gonna be you I don't try to make
all the things love they're movies I love and
I could never write them it's weird when it's
when you get started and when you probably
go to film school or something like that
you maybe you confuse your taste with what you
produce but sooner or later you realize that you
can love certain kind of movies that you will
never make or TV show I can watch sitcoms I'll
never I never write sitcoms it's not natural to
me but I I'm happy to exist I have a Maya Angelou
quote here and it is you can't use up creativity
the more you use the more you have foreign
yeah another of those Concepts know what it is
but I know I can't describe it I know that you
can stimulate it it's it's we don't necessarily
control what what what what stirs creativity
I know that I do know that when I'm not feeling
creative certain influences will help me get there
when I watched the latest PT Anderson movie in
a theater I was exhilarating I'm like I need
to make go make something now the same thing
some paintings can do that sometimes going on
a museum can stimulate you going to concerts or
even listening to some music alone and meeting
certain friends sharing experiences anything
can stimulate creativity sometimes maybe even
spiritual religious practices going out for
a hike motion usually helps I feel like when
I'm too static or lazy the odds are I won't
feel creative but maybe you work out maybe you
take a long shower maybe you read and maybe you
I don't know go out for getting out of the house
I this for writers who usually
work from home or their office
getting a space to a different space
to work out change the location
so I agree with the quote.